There is one additional nice thing about Heun's method,
it gives us Heun's estimate for the next step and in parallel, we get Euler's estimate for free
and we can compare these estimates to find out the error that we are making.
By the way, the technical term for this type of method is an embedded
Runge-Kutta method if you want to look that up.
Remember the two types of errors are introduced before.
The one type of error that we're actually interested in, in the end, is the GTE,
the global truncation error by how far are we off after a finite's time?
What Heun's method allows us is to estimate the LTE, the local truncation error--
the error that we are making at each step.
Consider the distance between the Euler result for that step and the Heun result for that step.
As we saw earlier, Heun's result is much more accurate than Euler's result.
So what we see here is about the error of Euler's method.
The LTE of Euler's methods. I'm cheating a little here. I must take the velocity into account.
Of course, we have several dimensions, two dimensions concerning x
and two dimensions concerning velocity.
We have to take all of them into account.
So this term as well by how far is the Euler estimate follow velocity of from Heun's estimate?
You could simply form the sum here but that would look strange for physicists.
These are meters and these are meters per second--that does not work.
The most simple idea is to introduce a time in here and time of that simulation.
It did makes sense when the velocity is off by a certain amount,
but early in that simulation, that error did grow over the course of that simulation.
There's other ways of combining these differences--you could form the square here,
the square there, and then take the square root but to make things simple,
I'm simply using this distance plus the simulation time times that distance.
We know that the GTE, the global truncation error for Euler's method is a constant times the step size.
We can also show that the local truncation error is another constant times the step size squared.
You can check the plausibility of h² appearing here.
If I double the step size, I only need half as many steps. Each step has four times the error.
I need half as many steps which means that the total error is
multiplied by two which we know is the case, but I can do know is to change the step size as I go.
I do not need to specify the step size in advance.
Once method is able to estimate the perfect step size for a given accuracy,
assume that I did the first step with some step size whichever one I chose,
but what I want is that this error, the local truncation error of Euler's method is of a fixed size.
Let's call that tolerance. What I want is to find the step size.
Let's call it h² new, so that this error is off the fixed size called tolerance
which would be measured in meters, by the way with this type of error.
I can compute C from that very first step.
It would be the local truncation error divided by h² old and I can solve for the new step size.
So the method actually determines the right step size I should be taking given the tolerance.
I can solve for the new step size and find that the new step size is the old step size times
the square root of the tolerance divided by this local truncation error
that I can compute numerically.
So after we did the first step with the old step size, we got an estimate for a perfect step size
that produce the local truncation error of such tolerance for Euler's method
and we can keep doing that as we go.
The step size will be adjusted automatically. We do not have to worry about it.
The method would choose the step size for us.
One benefit of this method choosing the perfect step size for us,
is that we do not have to choose it upfront.
The other benefit is that the solution we'll be stepping at appropriate step sizes for instance,
when we come close to a planet and the trajectory gets more bent, we need more steps.
This method will automatically choose smaller steps as we go and eventually use larger steps again.